pourquoi ne reconnais-tu pas ta voix
dans un enregistrement par exemple en
fait c'est parce que tu t'entends en
double d'abord par la vibration de tes
eos qui va se répandre jusqu'à la Coclé
c'est un son plus étouffé qui sonne
grave tu peux l'entendre en te bouchant
totalement les oreilles la seconde voix
c'est celle qui fait vibrer l'air et
l'étepant celle que tout le monde entend
et elle elle est plus aigu du coup ta
voix sur un enregistrement sans la
vibration des os ça sonne différent plus
fluet ah et au passage les trucs du
style se plier les oreilles ou se
boucher une seule oreille pour entendre
sa voix c'est du pur Pipo le seul moyen
de l'entendre c'est bien un
enregistrement tout cela explique donc